we were talking earlier about shrooms
you said you've had some bad shroom
experiences
tell me about the craziest shroom
experience you you've had
you just put me on the spot listen we've
all i mean i don't know
about we've all had bad i don't know
because i don't want people to think i'm
weird you know what i'm saying like what
because you did shrooms no because like
my experience
oh yeah tell me what happened please
like i don't want them to be like
yo she was tripping so i saw a ufo
like i i was in brickell you know i was
looking out
looking at my hotel i saw a ufo
that's in miami right in miami yeah i
saw a ufo it was like four in the
morning
i'm laying with my boyfriend and we're
both looking at it
but we felt asleep but we were awake
it was weird it's like my mind was was
awake
but my eyes was closed but i was fully
awake i wasn't
asleep and then i opened my eyes so let
me not say my eyes was closed this is
not making sense
anywho i was laying down i was looking
out the window and i saw a ufo
i didn't want to say anything like yo
you see that ufo because
i didn't want to think i was crazy did
he see the ufo as well
let me tell you so the next day
i saw the uf i asked him like i told
somebody in front of him i'm like oh
you know i thought i saw ufo yesterday
he said i seen it too but i didn't want
to say anything because i thought i was
tripping
and i i wanted to see if you would bring
it up today and i was like yes
i saw it like i knew it was a ufo it was
doing this little weird [ __ ] and then it
just
shot and disintegrated like shot down
and disintegrating what the [ __ ] flies
down everything flies up you know what
i'm saying it was like
yo what's crazy is they just put a video
out
uh this this do you see that video that
just came out that they confirmed is
real
uh it's like a naval ship and they have
like their radar thing
and um the they they the government said
it it's like a real video
i know because i've been meeting people
that have seen it it was in the school
not that but ufos no it was a ufo
in the sky over the water and then it
dived down into the water and
disappeared
that's what i saw that's what i saw
yeah i'm not kidding bro like and obama
just came out
two days ago and said that the [ __ ] is
real there's ufos so i don't know
exactly what it was but i know that that
wasn't something that
was normal i've never seen it again i
was only i only seen it on shrooms
so ever since i've been wanting to like
you know
i've just been wanting to see some [ __ ]
like that again but i feel like you can
only crack those levels
maybe on like the right amount of
shrooms you know yeah i think that uh
there
i mean listen i mean there's no proven
science but i think if you
something something gets unlocked in
your brain maybe you could see things a
little bit different you know your third
eye gets a little
i don't know man i mean you know how
[ __ ] starts melting sometimes when
you're on shrooms
oh i know like one time my whole fridge
was melting like i looked it left
sliding down i'm like what is going on
yeah the last time i did shrooms i was
in texas
and me and freddie gibbs were at a bar
[ __ ] up and there was some chick
dancing by herself and her face was
censored like she was on cops
what her face was all scrambled and she
like she's like you know like there was
a sensor like her face was censored
and i was like bro i was like bro you
see this [ __ ] like
am i tripping or is her face [ __ ]
like she looks like she's on an episode
of cops and did he see it
uh i don't think he's i was really
[ __ ] up he wasn't as [ __ ] i was
[ __ ]
that was a rough night for me that was
one of the worst nights of my life as
far as just freaking the [ __ ] out
but yeah that was yeah yeah i think you
know it's interesting because you do
hear that a lot when people do it
together
they usually see the same [ __ ] we just
had
whiz was telling us that about his mom
he said him and his mom
uh they did trooms together at coachella
and they saw all the same [ __ ]
i would love to do shrooms with my mom
that's lit